[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number is it 81
it is 81. today we collectively comprise
a perfect square
i am not as square as people imagine not
at all just like to say
but between all of us oh here we go at
the dark horse podcast
the three of us involved all right
perfect square the three of us are a
perfect square which is kind of
geometrically weird but
you know i get it and if you're going to
be a square might as well be perfect
that's nice absolutely yep all right
so uh well uh we'll start with some
announcements let's do that
um talk about where we're going today
and we have a couple ads at the top of
the hour before we get right into it so
announcements include uh as always we
encourage you to join us at our patreons
right now at my patreon the 48 hour
window that is monthly for
asking questions is open so at the 11
or more level you can go there and
pose a question and we will um try to
get to it those those q a sessions that
we do in the last sunday of the month
are quite a lot of fun
and the live chat is small enough that
we can actually engage with the chat
which of course we don't do
uh in these larger uh live streams
where we're going today we're going to
um
talk a little bit about keeping why it's
important to keep track of who actually
got it right
right and um and pattern recognition
and some other things in the space of
uh how how to use the scientific method
to discern what is actually true
how to science good i think would be the
way to say that that
might be a way that some people might
say that they could
try it on that is true um we're going to
talk just a little bit about
some more benefits of being physically
active as if there weren't already
enough known um we are going to find
that trans ideology has come to both
kickboxing and taxonomy
thank goodness and finish with
a poem that i found on the streets of
portland uh a beautiful poem
and um we're actually gonna finish with
two pro bono ads at the end
um oh i guess one more announcement
before we get into the um the paid ads
paying our mortgage for for the week um
in last week's episode we talked a lot
about ivermectin
and you finished that uh segment by
taking some
on air you had researched what the
prophylactic dose was
and you offered it to me and i said you
know it would be
it would be unlike me and uncareful even
as much as i trust you and love you to
do that
without any uh any forewarning without
doing my own due diligence and research
so
so i did and i have and indeed we
uh then posed uh the question with
all of the information to our two
children 17 and 15
and they um also chose to to join us in
that so
um we are all on prophylactic doses of
fibromyactin at this point and none of
us have experienced any ill effects and
i have to say while it is obviously
completely psychological in nature i do
feel uh protected based on what we have
uh
read about the effect of ivermectin well
and that's consistent with what i've
heard from a few people
who have been vaccinated that now they
just feel like this weight is lifted off
of them like now you can actually engage
um more safely in the world than you
have been able to engage
since i don't know february of 2020. so
yeah all right all right um so yeah time
um time to pay the rent time to pay the
rent
all right um i'm gonna begin
uh by talking about omax cryofreeze as
we have talked to you about here before
pain is useful it is a signal from your
body that something is amiss
or has been pushed too hard but
sometimes pain is too much
and as long as you don't push harder
after alleviating pain
it's wonderful if you can get rid of it
if you have chronic pain this is all the
more true
and as chronic pain can be debilitating
and there is really
little upside if you have as i do
persistent deep injuries from a trauma
from which you are still recovering
after many years
but which sometimes leave you leaves you
with pain that is difficult to manage
omax cryofreeze can be an effective tool
in your arsenal
you should not push through the pain you
should find the right kinds of bodywork
and activity to heal yourself and get
back to full functionality
and also a useful tool in this arsenal
is if you're sore and you need a break
from the pain and you aren't going to
push yourself further because you've
alleviated the pain
consider this product omax cryofreeze
i've used it over the last couple of
months and it does seem
to be helpful it's a combination of cbd
and menthol and it uses some other
botanicals like
aloe and arnica it's a paraben free
formula it's easy to roll on it doesn't
stink it's no mess
it's really quite a lovely product so
omax health is offering our listeners 20
off of a full bottle of cryo-free cbd
pain relief roll-on
and that discount 20 off also applies to
any product site-wide
go to omaxhealth.com today and enter
horse
nope enter code darkhorse
that's omax omaxhealth.com
enter the code darkhorse to get 20 off
cryofreeze and
also sitewide all right
um and i'm going to talk to you about
vpns and in particular expressvpn
so i want to break this down into a
couple different categories
do you need a vpn yeah you do need a vpn
and there are two reasons that you need
a vpn
one reason is that there's content that
you may want to access that you have
trouble accessing from your location
so although i am not a medical doctor
and therefore cannot recommend that you
watch the bbc
if you're an american and you want to
watch the bbc and you're willing to take
the risks that come along with watching
the bbc you may have to
make your computer appear as if it is in
the british isles in order for the bbc
player to work
expressvpn will help you do that i know
you're giving me that look but it is
true
and then the other big reason that you
need a vpn
is that you are constantly being tracked
on the internet and you are being
modeled and this
facilitates people uh invading your
privacy
and figuring out how to manipulate you
in ways that we can scarcely imagine so
if you want to immunize yourself from
that
you need your computer not to be easily
identified as associated with you and a
vpn will do interesting things like
it will pull your identity under a
shared
ip address which therefore does not have
a particular
character so
you do need a vpn why should it be
expressvpn it should be expressvpn
because
expressvpn is absolutely excellent what
makes it excellent
that it's mostly seamless they have
servers all over the world
they're very rapid and you don't notice
their interaction
for the most part so if you decide
you want to get expressvpn what you
should do is you should go
to expressvpn.com darkhorse
expressvpnexpressvpn.com
darkhorse and um
that will get you a vpn it will help
support the podcast and it will
anonymize you online
and you'll get three extra months for
free and you get three extra months for
free i forgot to mention that i know
it's here on the paper somewhere but i
misplaced it somehow that's probably
also because i'm not a medical doctor
i don't think so you don't think so no
all right
[Music]
all right um you wanted to believe uh
believe
believe
um you wanted to begin by talking about
um the move to script
history and what we understand to be
true and how it is that we understand to
be true uh how it is that we understand
things to be true basically a
a sort of a sociology of epistemology a
sociology epistle i mean that's
two words that probably most people
would flinch at and
probably have just lost a considerable
part of our audience no it sounds
scintillating does it not
i mean not really actually but it is
it's more scintillating than you would
think
so yeah actually i would say a couple
things have collided with each other
this week and they you know unleashed a
flurry of thoughts that i think are
important and so we're going to
develop them a little bit here one thing
that we have
is we have the mainstream
press falling all over itself
to script the story of how we went for
from knowing for sure
that coveted 19 did not leak from a
laboratory
to being open to the possibility that it
very well may have
right so obviously things have been
moving on this front over the course of
more than a year but suddenly the
mainstream has been
forced to change course and acknowledge
what it can no longer
deny and so the question is for all of
the people who should have let us know
that this was actually visible early on
who failed to let us know and in fact
kept doubling down on the idea that this
was a preposterous notion
they have to explain themselves in such
a way that they do not
degrade their position of authority in
the world
we would expect them to want to do that
why we would let them do that as a
different question
but nonetheless you can watch in real
time
as the mainstream attempts to construct
the story
of why it got the possibility of a lab
leak
wrong and why it is now still worth
listening to
having made that error and so you can
see this in a few places
you can look at donald
mcneal's piece donald mcneil actually is
an interesting case donald mcneil
was the lead kovid 19 reporter
at the new york times who lost his
position
when a strange scandal emerged
uh after it was discovered that years
prior on a trip in which he had led
students in peru he had uh
not used the n-word but he had said the
n-word in a discussion
of its meaning and implications and
apparently that was simply
too much for the pearl clutching class
and he was unceremoniously booted from
the new york times and of course
in that situation we would certainly
have supported
his continuation there
but this week he came out with a piece
in which he attempts to describe the
new landscape and this piece focuses
very directly on the emergence of
nicholas wade's piece
in the bulletin of concerned scientists
and medium
last week and it effectively describes
the story
in terms that viewers of our podcast
will regard as somewhat preposterous
let me see if i can find the salient
paragraph
um people can't hear you when you're in
front of your microphone
sorry so here he says for about a year
there was general wisdom among science
writers the lab leak theory by the way
he should say hypothesis but theory
migrated back to the far right where it
had
where it had started championed by folks
who brought us pizzagate
plandemic kung flu q anon stop the steel
and the january 6 capital
invasion it was tarred by the fact that
everyone backing it seemed to hate not
just
democrats in the chinese communist party
but even the chinese themselves it
spawned racist rumors
like chinese labs sell their dead
experimental animals
to food markets and then
he skips and he says and now to the
present day two weeks ago my former new
york times science news colleague
nicholas wade wrote an article in the
bulletin of atomic scientists and on
medium
arguing that the lab leak theory
deserves a harder look
okay so anyway he makes this move in
which he completely ignores
all of the people who didn't get this
wrong right
nicholson baker josh rogan
sagar and jetty and crystal ball
matt ridley i'm i'm going to
hold it there because the list of people
who didn't get it wrong
is quite long and involves a lot of uh
interesting important people i think uh
steve hilton
on fox actually deserves quite a lot of
credit for courageously
looking at this story in any case there
is this move
to create the impression that this story
was so
polluted by the nature of the people who
were discussing it
that it was actually responsible to get
it wrong because you wouldn't want to
have trafficked
in uh conjecture by those people when in
fact that is not the right story and
then
to my mind maybe even worse david frum
came out with a
piece this week that makes the very same
move
it is a piece bizarrely titled the
pro-trump culture war
on american scientist zach do you want
to put it out yeah
and i looked at this piece and
was very interested to see from's
perspective and then was
quite disturbed to find that it was
absolutely obsessed with donald trump
which of course has had nothing
to do with the discussion uh in
responsible circles of the lab league
hypothesis for the last year
hence the sociology of epistemology
right the applying of
human social truths to an understanding
to an analysis of an understanding of
what is actually true
yes it is uh it is a social
first epistemology in which the actual
truth is subordinate to
narrative which is of course absolutely
antithetical
to the scientific method from in this
piece
mentions trump no less than 29 times you
counted
i had my computer count it was easier
one's eyes tend to glaze over as it
jumps from trump to trump to trump
but the point is he makes the very same
move in which he describes
basically he does not use the term
basket of deplorables but the piece
effectively describes those who got this
right as a basket of deplorables
and only after nicholas wade had
cracked the case was it possible for
people to see that this was actually
quite a logical hypothesis
now of course those of you who have been
paying attention to the dark horse
podcast
know that this has long been discussed
by responsible voices and that that
story doesn't make any sense
i will say there was also a tweet by
uh maddie iglesias earlier this week in
which
he does slightly better than from ann mc
and mcdonald
neil sorry donald mcneil and he
says that actually what cracked the case
and brought it into the mainstream was
nicholson baker's article which is
closer to the truth but nonetheless
there is a long history
of scientific work and a journalist who
was actually interested
in how this story had evolved over this
period of time would have to
go no farther than the internet in order
to be able to reconstruct
that narrative the actual one exactly um
i'd like to just read one paragraph from
a piece that i published this week
an areo on which is called what if we're
wrong
right and it is exactly about these
these issues it begins with these
questions what if the earth isn't the
center of everything
what if the ancestors of humans once
looked like monkeys or were
single-celled organisms what if the
continents move
these questions were once beyond the
pale they were not to be discussed in
polite society were outside the frame of
the overton window
none of that made them untrue however
unimportant and then
as the as the article proceeds i ask the
questions you know what if sars kobe 2
emerged from a lab um what if there are
long-term effects of mrna vaccines what
if ivermectin has a safe and effective
prophylaxis against and treatment for
covet 19.
of course the answers to these questions
are not resolved any
all of them might the answer the answer
to all of them might be it didn't there
aren't
and it's not safe right um but the
posing of questions is
absolutely necessary to to the
conducting
of science and so i also talk about
pasteurian here a little bit
and this is the paragraph that i wanted
to read for every pastor
uh louis pasteur uh who obviously among
many many other contributions to modern
science
uh created the first rabies vaccine for
every posture there must be thousands of
people who have had an idea that didn't
pan out as well as countless others
whose ideas were good but never got
traction
science depends on the tenacity of the
person with a new idea even when others
take pleasure in mocking it
and if science depends on individuals
with tenacity then society depends on
all conversations being possible
the adults who mocked pasture before he
was successful in creating a
rabies vaccine were simultaneously
small-minded and arrogant
on the basis that he lacked the
appropriate credentials many medical
doctors of the time scorned pasture and
his work
last year's contemporaries imagined that
the current consensus was all there
would ever be
to know i don't know if there was a
trump in pastor's time
or if there was some other easy fall guy
easy scapegoat
with which to ignore him mock him deride
him
but every every single person
in in whatever is the modern moment in
history seems to imagine
who is engaged in this sort of thing
that finally we've arrived at the true
moment finally we've arrived at the
moment from which we can see everything
and it's akin to declaring themselves
god i mean it really
is the height of arrogance yeah and the
fact is at any of these moments there
are lots of people who know better and
the question is are you gonna listen to
the people who do know better or
don't and you know we have had the
experience of being
ridiculed for our position on
uh the lab leak hypothesis from the
beginning and so
we know what it's like to be portrayed
as right-wing
or wild-eyed or you know tin foil hat or
whatever it is and then
when it finally comes around you get to
see the evolution
of what has to be acknowledged
so until very recently my feeling was
you know what as long as we get there um
maybe it doesn't matter
that much about making sure that um that
the right credit is due but
largely through conversations with you i
have come to a different position
i'd like you know either i can play
devil's advocate
uh for the other side or just you know
just pose to you as if
i as if i still have what i think now is
a naive position why does it matter
aren't you being petty doesn't it matter
most that we actually now have all the
hypotheses live on the table and are
moving forward
yeah um i want to answer that question
directly but i want to
pair what we've already got here with
the lab leak
hypothesis and the jump that it has
taken um
with another story that we have a very
different position on
all right so this is the story of
so-called uaps which is i guess
a kind of uh acronym
euphemism for ufo and
the fact is that it's the acronym used
in um
in in military in in the dod yeah i
don't know when
exactly that became the term but
you know i would imagine there was a
discussion somewhere that said if we
call them
ufos which is of course a perfectly
neutral term they're unidentified they
fly
right who could doubt it but the point
is that term is searchable
and so somebody came up with a different
acronym that you wouldn't necessarily
guess but anyway the point is this story
has taken
a quantum leap in terms of its
discussability
this week 60 minutes did a story
on uaps in which they interviewed
military personnel who'd had encounters
some of them described having
encounters on a daily basis for over a
year
so suddenly we are able to discuss this
at the level
of the cocktail parties that are
reflective of 60 minutes as an
authoritative
source now of course the new york times
had had a
discussion of some of the same
observations uh
very recently so what we're watching is
the evolution of discussability
now one of the incidents that was in the
60 minutes
piece a focus of the 60 minutes piece
dates back to 2004
and it's an incident that has four high
level
witnesses airborne at the time of their
interaction
who all make a very credible case they
don't claim to know what they saw
but they and they all acknowledge that
had they seen it with no one else
present they would have been hesitant to
say anything because they know it would
call their
credibility into question but given that
they're for them the courage existed
to discuss it nor are they in any way
attention seeking they don't want to be
on you know the
one of the people says i never want to
be on national television talking about
this this is not
this is not my goal here right so anyway
very credible witnesses right these are
highly technical serious people who saw
something and they don't know what it
was but
it's hard to dismiss it as any normal
phenomenon
but it goes back to 2004 and i know
because of some of the sources that i
look at for things that
you know will clue me into uh features
of the lab leak hypothesis that i don't
know about
i know that there's nothing at all new
about this discussion except the
discussability of it
there were serious discussability the
the the veil
of discussability as provided by the new
york times in 60 minutes is that what
you mean
yes that there is something going on and
it goes back to your point about
social epistemology there is something
about this topic even discussing it now
right if i am talking about an incident
in 2004
i'm on solid ground as long as i'm
talking about it from the perspective of
2021 where it is now discussable but the
fact is
that incident existed in 2004.
evidence has not changed and right and
there were serious people discussing
these kinds of incidents and military
observations
of them and not just a few 20 years ago
so the point is what do you do with the
discovery
that you and we were induced to be
timid about this story when the story
was every bit as
real and then we get permission to think
from something like the new york times
or 60 minutes or something like that
and we are in a different position on
the uap issue because we haven't been
early on
right we have no in fact we got a
question a couple weeks ago
after the new york times read its piece
like i have no idea and you know
joked about it seems yep seems like the
same old same old
i think if i don't remember exactly what
i said but my guess is what i said was
actually the stuff is more credible than
you would think right
but the point is is the dark horse
podcast way ahead on uaps
no we are not but we are in the same
position with respect to commenting on
the epistemological process
it just got safer it got safer and
that's why we're this is suddenly on
people's minds
not that anything new has happened you
know nicholas wade
did a beautiful job of summarizing
evidence that had been accumulating
over the course of more than a year he
didn't change the story he didn't add
anything to the story but he made it
discussable he gave cover
now back to your question yes why
why does it matter that we keep track of
who is early why does it matter that we
give credit where credit is due
right here's why it matters because this
process is an
evolutionary one and what is supposed to
happen so you've got
signal and you've got noise somebody
could get this right
early without understanding anything in
fact it's a strong argument to be made
that that's what happened with trump
that to the extent that he said anything
coherent
on the issue of lab leak he just had the
same
instinct on hearing the uh the the
evidence that this had emerged right
near alaska circumstantial evidence was
all he knew
he was all he knew it was being
discussed in places on the internet he
paid attention to and
he tossed off something because he
thought it worked in his advantage now
that doesn't
add or detract from the actual
credibility of the story in fact it has
zero weight right but
the point is okay you're going to get
some people who get lucky early
will they be able to repeat their
ability to predict the future no you
will find an awful lot of noise and very
little signal
on the other hand somebody who has a
track record sorry but you also want to
keep track of
for those people who get lucky early is
it because they are
broadcasting predictions if they are
making you know 100 predictions and one
of them
turns out to be true um but the other 99
have disappeared into history
you know perhaps because they're just
constantly blathering about stuff
um that's also not an indication that um
that they have a you know finely honed
epistemological brain
right and so you have to pay attention
to the signal-to-noise ratio how
difficult to prediction is it how early
ought to count right how early relative
to the recognition
that it's real how many wrong
predictions of a similar type
are there right um so anyway you can
track that but the important thing if
the system is to get better at spotting
things that matter
in time to do something about them is
that the people who get stuff
right have to advance and the people who
get stuff
wrong have to have their uh the weight
of their opinion
downgraded now and you're not actually
making an argument like that that
argument would be true from say a market
perspective
it's you know it's it's good to
incentivize people
who are good at this to for them to know
that they will be able to advance right
that's sort of
that's that's the market reason to do
this but from the perspective of
science and knowledge and the well-being
of humanity and the planet
this is also you know in this in this
case uh the incentives are aligned we
actually need
to make sure to know who gets it right
early
because they are the ones who are most
likely to be able to
to see patterns in the future that other
people are not seeing
in combination with stand up against
the the matting crowd you know the the
social forces that say we don't
talk about that and if you do you're
wrong and you're bad all right this is
excellent those are two quite distinct
points yes in order for us to get
collectively smarter
you have to empower the people who are
capable of seeing
farther seeing earlier but also you want
to reward the people who
show evidence that they are actually
immune to the social incentives that
would have shut them up
and if you do advance those voices you
do get smarter and in this case you can
see
why that is in a position to affect
whether or not
millions of people die because at this
very moment
lab leak is the central question in
whether
we studied gain of function too much or
we studied it
not enough potentially right now again
if those of you who
follow along with our course we'll know
that we had a discussion very early
if you have to do gain a function
research which we do not believe you
have to do
but if you have to do gain of function
research we don't though
right much of the world seems to
civilization
needs to do gain of function research on
human pathogens
it should do it under circumstances that
are
safe and what i proposed was
such a thing if it needs to be done
could be done
on a ship right at sea far away from
other things
now again i don't think we need to do
this research i think it's more
dangerous than it's worth but if we
decide otherwise
you would want to take precautions like
that right so
something with no leaky borders right
exactly
you would want to have another uh system
to protect you and to the extent that we
now have all woken up to
the hazard of pathogens moving freely
about the globe so
a cold that starts in one part of the
globe is all over the place
inside of weeks right we could start
getting serious about the major human
cost of all of these relatively minor
pathogens
that are circulating and start figuring
out how to frustrate that process
right so anyway that would all be
worthwhile but everything depends on us
not
rehabilitating people who got it wrong
because they were socially motivated
and elevating people who were in fact
insensitive to the social incentives
and willing to see what was right in
front of them all along
and yes there are millions of lives at
stake and
i would also point out we have two forks
of the question of where the lives are
at stake
one of them has to do with a future lab
leak which is all too possible
the other has to do with whether or not
understanding
if this pathogen came from a lab what
were
the protocols that were used to generate
it
if we could understand what was done
that generated this thing
we would have a great deal more
predictive power with respect to its
future evolution for example
and by playing as if this is uh all
impossible to navigate um we have
slowed down the process of understanding
what what value there might be in
understanding
protocols that for example might have
created this in a way actually
um you know we've begun to say welcome
to complex systems right
i mean we've we've been saying it
privately for a long time but um
we've begun to say that here and i feel
like a recognition that many people have
at an intuitive level that
you know a virus is different from a
rock
and a virus that has been worked on
through some
fancy accelerating evolutionary change
research
in a lab is potentially going to be a
different thing from a regular from a
from a naturally
wild type virus from a rock a rock which
is not a complex system
um that it is actually that sort of
intuitive recognition that most people
have now that like
so much of the world is so complex and
most of us
don't have the background to assess from
first principles a lot of what we are
being told
and so there's a lot of this like hand
waving around
loudly and sars kovi 2 origins and in
fact vaccines
and in fact ivermectin and in fact all
of these stories
around this pandemic where it's kind of
like it's complex you wouldn't
understand
don't bother looking here besides also
you know the guy you don't like said it
um so it is in some ways uh it could be
viewed also as a weaponizing of the
concept of this is complex systems
and um you you know you you little
people
wouldn't understand well it goes back to
the distinction i draw between terms of
art and jargon
so my claim is that terms of art are
terms you have to invent or redefine
in order to discuss something technical
right they have to exist but it's a
necessary evil it's not a good thing
yeah right and then there's jargon which
is used to keep people out so they don't
know what you're talking about when you
could
you could well explain it right and so
yes it is being used as a territorial
protection and
you know you've got journalists who are
protecting their territory and now
have to protect it in spite of the fact
that they screwed up and i don't mean
it's a lab leak i mean they screwed up
pretending
or believing they're terrible sources
who said uh
couldn't possibly be right yes had they
looked into the evidence
and found that there was no reason to
pursue it and said
i'm not going there it's not worth my
time that's a very different kind
of you know mistake i i think it's still
a mistake but it's not one that
is opposed to the job of journalism
whereas
um whereas circling the wagons
around against a story against a
hypothesis
that has growing evidence in support of
it
and nothing to falsify it that is
against science it's against journalism
and it's against progress it is and
i there's another thing that just looms
into view there
right this is not like a historical case
where we're now
building the description of well here's
what actually happened and here's what
its implication is for who the
authoritative sources were
we've got i would say several live heads
to this hydra
right we have permission now to talk
in public about the lab leak hypothesis
and to not be snickered at or derided
for doing so
we don't yet have that permission with
respect to
ivermectin we don't yet have that
permission with respect to the actual
hazards of vaccines be they
short-term be they long-term be they
epidemiological all three of those
things are
places where we are headed with a
collision
uh headed for a collision with complex
systems specifically with the copit
vaccines you're not talking
more broadly well i mean i am talking
more broadly yes the covered vaccines we
have a particular problem because
they're so darn new and so there's so
little uh insight into what we
should expect going forward but you know
it turns out that we've got an overly
pretty view of vaccines because frankly
they are so highly effective they're
such a marvelous tool that
you know we tend to absorb the uh the
brochure version which is that these are
these
you know marvelous technological
advancements that
you know with just no downsides with no
downsides and it's just not right
um so anyway i guess i guess what i
would say
is again and again and again we see
analogous
failures and these analogous failures
are telling us something and one of the
things that you can see this week that
was harder to see
three weeks ago is what role
is what you have permission to think
about playing
in what you understand that could hurt
you right
i didn't know the term gain of function
research in
you know october of 2019.
i had not run across it right i now know
had it been described to you
you would have understood it as i would
have it's it's an it's
you know it is obvious in retrospect for
those with
evolutionary background right but here's
the thing i was asking before that date
all right in light of the financial
collapse of 2008 in light of fukushima
in light of the aliso canyon leak in
light of the deepwater horizon
accident in light of all of these things
where we discover
we in the public discover that we in
some technical field are doing some
really dangerous thing
that then we hear about at the point
something has gone wrong
right i've started asking the question
well
what are we doing that i should know
about now
before something has gone wrong and gain
a function research would have been a
great answer to that question we're
doing gain of function research oh that
sounds great on what
human pathogens oh we're enhancing
human pathogens i would imagine that we
are doing that at sea
where if such a thing escapes and
infects one of the people doing the work
we're not all going to infect it is that
in fact what we're doing oh no
we're we're doing it across the you know
road from a seafood market
um so that's a great list i mean that
that
a partial list like that shows up in our
book as well but you mentioned
um the financial collapse of 2008 aliso
canyon
fukushima and deepwater horizon um i
wanted to just say those again i don't
know if you want to spend just a
minute on each of those or maybe not
sure so uh the financial collapse of
2008 is very famous i probably don't
need to say very much if you
are curious about this and you don't
mind
pain you could watch the big short and
get a really good idea of what what
happened but basically
uh the bubble game was uh it came to
visit the
mortgage market and got amplified by
processes
so arcane that no one would have thought
to ask about them
and obviously almost crashed the world
economy that's one
alizo canyon was a
natural gas leak where we had been
injecting
natural gas for storage in southern
california
in a uh an emptied
uh crude oil deposit so basically we had
a pressurized crude oil deposit full of
natural gas and it sprung a leak and was
hard to plug it was very reminiscent of
what took place
in the gulf of mexico at the deepwater
horizon uh
accident where we had uh drilled into a
very large crude oil deposit in
the floor of the gulf and at the point
that they had a blowout
the technology to plug the blowout did
not exist the
fail-safes had not worked and um
they had leaked extensively fukushima we
had a
triple meltdown in japan as the result
of a tsunami that swamped the diesel
generators that were supposed to keep
electricity
running to the reactors and it turns out
that when
fission reactors do not have power fed
to them they melt down so we had a
triple meltdown
one of those meltdowns in reactor
building 3 actually appears to have been
a prompt criticality where a
nuclear chain reaction unfolded the
other two were hydrogen explosions where
the radiation had torn apart
water and left hydrogen and oxygen
highly flammable and had blown apart the
buildings
and frankly it could have been much much
worse if those fuel pools had cracked
which they didn't but
because we were lucky so anyway these
are all places where our technology
allowed us to do something that we were
the technology to control what we had
done was far
behind the technology that allowed us to
get into trouble
there it is yep and all of these uh
the financial collapse of 2008 is the
earliest of those so this is
it would appear and this is not a a
careful statement that's backed up with
any statistical analysis but it would
appear
that we are putting ourselves at ever
greater risk as we as we have
um ever greater numbers of people who
are
even tighter specialists who are doing
work outside of the view
of you know of those of us who could
assess it and as simultaneously
journalism and academia fall apart with
regard to their ability
or willingness to actually keep eyes on
these things
so you know what if if coveted 19 turns
out to be another one of these
this is by many measures the biggest
uh and and what's next what's next
and you know okay we've got a discussion
about
gain of function research and the
cost-benefit analysis we have
dr fauci who apparently played a key
role
in lifting the ban on gain of function
research which may well have led
to this pandemic and we have richard e
bright
who has been attempting to call people's
attention to the danger
of this kind of research who do you want
looking out for you
in the discussion of whether or not we
should do future gain of function
research
on human pathogens i want richard
ebright there
right now the question is if we get the
right story of what happened and we say
all right where is richard ebright in
that story how early was he
how accurate were his predictions then
the answer is oh yeah of course you want
him in the room
it's not going to be easy right he's
going to
set a high bar but that's what you want
you want somebody to set a high bar for
you
do i want fouchy there well i sure as
hell don't want him there if he doesn't
admit what role he played here
and frankly i probably don't want him
there at all right
he um he obviously led us into danger
whether that danger actually resulted in
the lab leak i hope we find out but
um but nonetheless you're really talking
about a battle between people
mostly you haven't heard of who did get
it right and might have protected us
from this
and people who got it wrong who would
like to hold on to their credibility and
obscure
basically airbrush the others out of
history right
all right are we there i think so all
right
um let's talk briefly about a paper that
came out
this recently called and you can show my
screen if you like
zachary by a crew of researchers salus
at all
published in the boy i've lost track of
where it
is published in the british journal of
sports medicine
called physical inactivity is associated
with a higher risk for severe covid19
outcomes
a study in 48 440 adult patients
and most most of the conclusion is
discernible from that
from that title but i will read to you
just a couple of paragraphs from the
introduction as well
the u.s centers for disease control and
prevention the cdc
has identified risk factors for severe
cove at 19 including advanced age
sex male and the presence of underlying
comorbidities such as diabetes obesity
and cardiovascular disease
however there are no data regarding the
effect of regular physical activity on
cova-19 outcomes even though a lack of
physical activity is a well-documented
underlying risk factor for multiple
chronic diseases
including those associated with severe
copen19
they then go on to say that the u.s
physical activity guidelines suggest
that all
american adults engage in 150 minutes of
activity every week and that includes
just a brisk walk actually counts
towards this so what is that two and a
half hours of
um you know merely brisk walking
or or more a week of physical activity
counts as sort of meeting the guidelines
next paragraph during the pandemic
populations across the globe have been
advised to stay home and avoid contact
with individuals outside of one's
household
lockdowns and other measures that
constrain travel have restricted access
to gyms parks and other venues where
people can be active
in the usa education about the benefits
of physical activity
and advice to maintain or increase
physical activity during the pandemic
has been essentially absent
while pre-pandemic levels of physical
activity were generally insufficient
pandemic control measures have likely
had the unintended consequence of
reducing physical activity even more
indeed early studies indicated a
significant reduction of physical
activity levels since the beginning of
the pandemic
so that's that's the setup and indeed
they uh refer
to another paper uh that was published
just last year which does indeed find
that while
and this is all it's self reports and
indeed this paper itself is self reports
of physical activity as well but it's
it's a way of self reporting that has
been
otherwise demonstrated to be um pretty
accurate
um we know that
the people reporting on their levels of
physical activity
in the wake of lockdowns many people are
saying it's the same
but to the extent that people are saying
it's it's different
uh many more people are saying i don't
do as much as i did before than are
saying i'm doing more than i was before
though there are some people
in that in that other state too so if
this is all true
[Music]
and if physical activity has an effect
on covet 19 outcomes
then we've got at the very least yet
another strong messaging problem
and indeed uh what this paper finds
is um let's see i'm not sure
yeah there was no the graphics here
aren't terrific um so i'll just go to
one more paragraph in the discussion the
magnitude of risk for all
outcomes associated with being
consistently inactive exceeded the odds
of smoking
and virtually all the chronic diseases
studied in this analysis
indicating physical activity may play a
crucial role as a risk factor for severe
copa 19 outcomes
so you know again uh like we've talked
about before with regard to obesity
there are some there are some things
that aren't even hidden but that are
hidden from conversation that are hidden
within in the media that are not
discussed
that you actually have control over and
even more than obesity because
you know some people once they have
become obese especially if that's due to
developmental
uh intrusions into their lives over
which they no longer have any control
because now they're adults
many people who are obese are actually
going to have a very hard time getting
unobese and that's not to say that you
don't have agency but it's tough
but do you have an ability to get active
does everyone in fact have an ability
to simply walk briskly for two and a
half hours a week i i say
yes and are there rare exceptions and if
you don't sure
it's an emergency that you develop that
capacity that you build up to it
exactly so i just wanted to add here i
don't think this paper
discusses masks it discusses activity
but i want to point out the absurdity
in light of this of two things one
you know as we pointed out over the last
couple of weeks
the idea that one has to wear a mask
outside which is completely unscientific
manufacturing anti-scientific conclusion
but that conclusion portrays the world
as a hundred percent dangerous where it
is in fact
99 safe by virtue of the fact that it's
99 outdoors and the thing doesn't seem
to spread outdoors at least it hasn't
learned that trick yet
but the the fact of that missed
portrayal
in conjunction with the idea that even
outside
because it's all dangerous you must wear
a mask that idea which reigned until
a couple of weeks ago that means that to
the extent
that there was a question about should
you go outside
and be active there were really two
things marshalling against it one was
outside is dangerous so yeah you should
probably go out and be active but
you know it's you're not escaping covid
out there even though you really are
but the second thing is that it
complicates being highly active
right as bad as it is walking around
with a mask walk running around with a
mask
or biking around with a mask or any of
those things is awful
and so it makes it less likely that
people will choose to do it it's harder
to do
and and in many places it was actually
forbidden for a while to
just go outside at all and i think
indeed one of the one of the studies we
talked about earlier which had this very
strange result about dog walking being
associated with
with higher rates of covid and i think
that was in spain uh after we
talked about it we heard from a number
of people actually this was uh
if memory serves in a city where a lot
of people are living in high-rise
apartments and the one thing you're
allowed to do is walk your dog
and in order to get your dog down to
walk them you have to be in these
elevators which are these tight
you know enclosed spaces and so probably
this was you know the dog walkers were
just simply the only people
who were going up and down the elevators
with any regularity and that was likely
to be the
the issue but anyway there are a lot of
people who just weren't even allowed to
go outside
right weren't allowed to go outside but
imagine for a second
that the actual adults had been looking
at the actual evidence and making actual
recommendations for how you
actually avoid covid and they had
concluded you know what
physical exercise is key obesity
is a disaster masks
are potentially helpful but not outdoors
and they impede
the very behaviors that are most likely
to make you well
psychological well-being is increased by
your going outside
so sit down everybody here's the
recommendation
go outside spend as much time outside
as you can go to the beach have a good
time at the beach
you know remind yourself what it is like
to live without
fear if you had had that kind of
recommendation
this would have been a very different
pandemic and instead we were having
officials close down beaches right close
close
limit you know you can't play tennis i
mean there's still signs up i think it's
it's allowed now but in portland i was
taking pictures and showing them on air
all through last summer yes the swimming
pools were closed and i think at that
point we didn't fully know if maybe
water transmission was
possible so i did not come down strongly
against that it felt like a
tragedy for the children but um but okay
but you know sporting fields no baseball
no basketball no football no
tennis not even for kids yeah you know
kids who were immune by virtue of the
fact that kovid does not seem highly
capable of infecting or
damaging kids they could have had sports
and other activities
outside they engaged with each other
engaged with each other this
so much of the harm here was needless
and there's something about it
which one just has the impression that
there's a certain kind of authoritarian
that likes spoiling people's fun and
so instead of embracing the
counter-intuitive facts about covet and
saying you know what
covet is a disease of indoors it's the
buildings that are dangerous
if you can figure out how to stay out of
the buildings and
really think very hard about how not to
be in a car or if it's winter and
you know open the windows all the way
and turn the heat up if it's winter
these sorts of pieces of advice about
how to continue to live a normal life
we would i think we'd in some ways be
like a different people at this point
because we would all discover what it
was like to be advised
actually you know the dangers in your
house but out there
you're safe and you know we might as
well i wouldn't say the dangers in your
house the danger is not in your house if
you you know if you aren't
letting lots of strangers come and come
and go the danger is about being
indoors among other people who might be
infected well
i i slightly disagree i mean i think
your your caution is accurate but
a lot of what was true here was that
once
covid got loose in a house it tended to
bounce around to anybody who could catch
it absolutely and actually that you know
that
that mode of transmission is um appears
to be
if not the one of the most absolutely
most dangerous
to have somebody bring cove at home so
which is like you know
again another of the recommendations uh
you know across the u.s anyway and i
don't know how widespread this was
outside of the u.s was
if you get sick given that we're so
worried about icu beds what you do is
you go home
really you just guaranteed a lot more
people are gonna get sick yeah
right exactly and so anyway i just
we will never know but i do wonder
if this might not have been an
enlightenment if instead of having
fingers wagged at us for smiling
outdoors at each other without a mask on
or whatever it was
right if instead of being scolded for
natural the sense of relief that you
should have had outdoors for those of us
who did experience it
right we also experienced stigma for
apparently not being decent
right that was preposterous that wasn't
science well i mean there was just
across pretty much every domain that
that sarsko v2
touched there were simple rubrics that
people
felt empowered to use against other
people to increase tribalism to increase
fear to make them their own cells feel
better and just you know here's an
anecdote which maybe i've mentioned
before but i was
walking outside without a mask at one
point a
big broad path and there was a woman
coming towards me with a mask
and she saw me and she saw someone way
behind me
and gestured at her and yelled in my
general direction
thank you for wearing a mask like you
are yelling
you are actually spri if you are sick
the mask is not going to fully block
when you're yelling and i'm
not speaking because i'm actually
interested in not getting you sick and
i'm six more than six feet away from you
and all of these things are true
and the idea that signaling to someone
you don't know
about how awful i am is making you feel
better
you know can't can't we all get a life
at some level like aren't we all capable
of bringing something to the world that
actually builds it up don't we
all have some ability to create or to
build
or to heal or to communicate or
to to adventure to discover to analyze
like these are all productive
amazing activities and i haven't begun
to
you know to exhaust all the possible
verbs
of productivity and and
and and building that humans can involve
themselves in and you know
is critique a important part of the
human endeavor it certainly is but
anyone whose job entirely is about
critique
is not really doing the world of service
yeah i mean i agree although um you know
i sort of think of critique as
the good version and criticism but i
but i this i i'm not sure that most
people will agree with me i'm not sure
that anyone
really well but i actually thought about
this and i don't think that as much as
critique and criticism are
kind of flip sides with different
connotations and critique is the
positive and we know that critique is
absolutely necessary in science and in
art and
all endeavors if the only thing you
engage in is critique
i don't think you were doing the world
the kind of service that you imagine you
are
oh yeah definitely um
i guess i'm uh there's a sense
you know how there were teachers who had
a really deep insight into
human development and yes they were part
of the schools but
they also were sort of above that level
of
uh you know rules and regs right
they were flexible they had nuance they
were about discretion
and then there were other teachers who
were just all about the enforcement of
the rules to
the letter without any consideration of
why the rules
necessarily existed i feel like we are
all somehow being reduced to some
schoolyard that is being ruled by the
least imaginative
buzz-killing rule-loving authoritarian
nanny teachers and we just
gotta rebel right yeah the fact is there
are places where the rules are essential
and there are other places where
somebody made them up because they
wanted to tell you what to do
well there's i guess there's three
categories really there's places where
the rules are essential and they have to
be the right rules
and then there are places where the
rules aren't essential but if you're
going to have rules they have to be the
right rules
and then there are places where you
don't need rules and if there are rules
at all you should be free to ignore them
right but in this case right
it is amazing to me that in some sense
the solution to a huge
number of the problems created by kovitt
problems that none of us invited
right a huge number of those problems
were solved
by going outside i mean even the social
distance that this put between us
didn't need to be maintained in the same
way outside that's right right and
you know if you know we have this saying
uh in the pacific northwest
there's no such thing as bad weather
just inappropriate clothing
you know if you have to discover what
you're gonna have to do in order to be
outside in the winter because
there's a new wrinkle that makes it hard
to be inside right okay
that's the thing we should have advised
people here's you know here's the
the gentle slope to getting yourself
active in cold weather in your
environment or something like that
and you know i just i i i feel terrible
for our species
that we allowed this to happen to us and
not just
you know the disease but the way we
botched
the coping mechanism we just screwed it
up well
i love this framing of yours you know
the idea that instead of this
just debilitating debacle worldwide
debacle that we find ourselves in now
it actually could have been the
opportunity for another enlightenment
yeah how tragic yeah utterly tragic
utterly tragic and
it's tragic but you know what there's a
reason we focus on tragedy and that's
because
you can learn from it and that's right
you know we don't know what the next
thing that has the magnitude of covid
could be it's hard to imagine such a
thing but you know what
given the way disasters are going the
magnitude is going up
something is going to be down the pike
let's not screw it up next time that's
right
okay slight change of pace but no more
uplifting really um now you know this
this week in
sex and gender madness yeah um
i actually i want to i wanted to this
week and i definitely want to at some
point talk about some of the
diabolical stuff that's going on in
schools uh
with regard to you know what is
happening under the auspices of sex ed
and inclusivity and i've heard from some
parents on this topic
and i went looking for those emails or
notes this week and i could not find
them so if you're listening
please send them to me again because i
know that there is some
some stuff going on um in many school
districts
uh that are uh that are worthy of
discussion here
um absent that though i
wanted to talk a little bit about
kickboxing and an ant named they
um
you know just because uh first though
here is uh the kickboxing thing
oops there we go oh boy that wasn't good
at all
um there we go so the british kickboxing
council an organization i had not
previously been aware of
tweeted in the end of march today we
celebrate hashtag trans day of
visibility as our trans inclusion and
kickboxing project continues
access to sport they say is a
fundamental human right supported by the
olympic charter
please read emily's story and check out
mermaid's uk
brand new active about inclusion website
below um so for those of you who don't
know mermaids uk
is uh an ideological organization that
is doing tremendous amount of harm and
of course they're claiming to be about
the new civil rights fight for
you know trans awareness and inclusion
but um it's really quite
i'm just gonna use the word again
diabolical actually um
but when you when you go into this
site what you find is that the british
kickboxing council is proud that now
they're gonna let
trans women um compete against women
so i said in response to that quote
tweeting for those of you who
are unfamiliar blissfully unaware of
twitter what i said was
this week in progress men can kick women
for fun and if you object
you're the problem to which someone uh
who said who is on twitter as a
quote-unquote enlightened scientist
says responds to me anyone who has been
involved in martial arts knows men and
women and boys and girls frequently
sparred together and learning about
inclusion respect and fairness are
fundamental to this principle
i'm not sure what the problem is here
really probably we can just leave it
there but
anyone who invokes the
cool fact that at this point in history
certainly girls and boys
but let's put that aside for the moment
but that men and women can get together
and engage in sport together including
martial arts
on a friendly basis conflating that
with competition which pretends that men
and women are the same and that all you
have to do to be
for to turn from one into the other is
to declare that you have
is so misunderstanding of reality and
frankly so misogynistic and dangerous to
women who would compete
that not being you know being able to
finish a tweet with i'm not sure what
the problem is here well
really if you can't see what the problem
with encouraging men who've declared
themselves women to compete in
kickboxing against
women is i'm not sure how to help you
like what what do you say to him yeah
well
as you're talking i'm i'm seeing the
picture
even more clearly terrific here's what i
see
you've got two sides of this argument
one of them says trans rights
right it sees only that as an objective
and who could object
trans rights trans rights are good i
would agree trans rights are good
there's the other side that recognizes
that there's a tension between something
which is you would like to give trans
people
as much leeway to live in a way that
feels authentic and right to them as you
can
but that if you just simply grant them
every right
as if they were born into the other sex
that you start infringing on things like
the protections of women and so
one side is engaged in a discussion of
how do we draw this
line so that the ideal balance is
discovered
right so that we do protect trans people
and we do protect
women and we do so simultaneously right
and the other side only wants to talk
about one side of a trade-off now in my
opinion
the side that wants to talk about one
side of a trade-off
is not offering anything it is a act of
purest advocacy
and we have an obligation not to listen
in some sense it's not even a complex
systems level problem
it's just a systems level problem well i
i
i agree um but also there are places in
this discussion about trans rights
uh where you know all all reasonable
people i've ever met
are interested in accommodating people
such that they can feel respected
regarding the choices they are making so
long as no
impinging is done on pre-existing rights
of other people
and so especially when what is required
is
i declare myself x but actually you know
we all know that i'm not but i declare
myself
x um that
at that point i'm not i am not
interested
actually in giving up any of the
hard-won rights of women
or children or homosexuals or
you know to sort of go slightly smaller
with each group in terms of the
the number of humans um who are
represented in each group
or female competitive athletes right and
so
you know sport is a human right i don't
know where that came from but like
imagine for a moment that you believe
that to be true
sport is a human right which again i
think is an absurd proclamation but even
if you think that's true
that is not the same thing as saying
therefore
anyone can compete against anyone else
if we want if if we want to do that
and acknowledge that actually we are no
longer interested in seeing women
win at sport or engage in team play or
you know be able to be competitive in in
informal
sport then we make everything unisex and
we watch
as men win yep that's it right and the
trans women won't win either against the
men but they will
will win against the women and sure
there are always going to be a couple of
exceptions
and that does not disprove the rule
because populations and individuals are
different
and at a population level men are going
to be stronger and faster and fiercer in
all of this than women
and therefore the elite among them will
be as well yeah
and in fact the tale of the distribution
is what the competition ends up being
about
exactly and that you know that is why
this this response from this
um whatever adjective he used for
himself this scientist
is insane you're talking about the tales
of the distribution
encouraging men and women to spar with
one another as they're both
learning to figure out you know maybe
some of the moves that men and women do
that are different
you know i don't kickbox i don't do
martial arts i don't know what they
would be but
that could be informative that could be
interesting it's not the same as
competition you're not talking about the
tales of distribution
right so i guess another way to look at
it
is the accusation
that is supposed to limit you know
you're not supposed to have permission
to discuss the difficulty
of trying to protect trans rights in the
context of pre-existing rights so we
don't have that permission yet so
we get stigmatized and the stigma is
one of bigotry now how can it be bigotry
if the description of the position that
you hold is
yep i am open to granting any right to
somebody to live
as they want to live up until the point
that it starts infringing on other
people's rights
that sounds like a completely
non-arbitrary place it does not sound
like anybody trying to deny somebody
something
right it sounds like trying to preserve
something and so
you know the solution here is that we
actually have to stare down the
accusation
yeah this has zero to do with bigotry
this is not about
wanting anything ill for trans people or
not favoring living authentic lives i'm
gonna go further i think
too often it has a lot to do with
misogyny actually not only does it have
nothing to do with bigotry
um but the people who are claiming that
those of us who are trying to defend
women's spaces and and
you know all the rest of it who those
people who are saying your bigots very
often what they're engaging is misogyny
is misogyny and
sometimes it's even conscious well so i
think a good way to ask the question
is given these two positions where are
the bigots
right good where are the bigots and in
fact this has been
a theme of recent history because of
course that was the thing that made
the the evergreen story and all of the
crt stuff so difficult for
the so-called mainstream press to deal
with was that the bigots were on a side
it wasn't used to them being on
and so it decided to pretend they
weren't there or that they were on the
other side
and that of course confused everything
but which side of the big it's on i
think is a fair question
and when your position is non-arbitrary
and is based on
uh preserving pre-existing rights rights
that were hard-won frankly
um that's obviously not motivated but by
bigotry you know you used to say
a lot uh something about the thing in
the package is not the wrapping paper
so what's the exact the label on the box
does not match the contents
yeah and so you know this is something
i used to joke when i was teaching
animal behavior for all those many years
um that uh you know wouldn't it be
easier if the squirrels or the the
butterflies or the monkeys could talk to
us and then we could just ask them
and you know if you've ever thought
about cultural anthropology and
ethnography and what it takes to
actually figure out what is true of
human behavior
or if you've just ever been a human
really you know
that we prevaricate all the time we lie
all the time and so it's actually much
easier um if you can as we've also said
turn down the volume
and watch what is actually happening and
then if you can
map if it is an organism that actually
communicates map the conversation onto
it or map the explanation of what's
going on to it
if it matches cool very often it won't
and then you have something to explain
and so you know it's actually easier to
do animal behavior than it is to do
human behavior
because they're very much the animals
that you're watching are very much less
likely to lie to you you have to learn
some different skills and you have to
learn different kinds of patients and
all of this but
um at least they're not trying to
convince you in exactly the mode of
communication that you
have as your most fundamental mode and
so
this thing that people are doing where
they're like all i have to do is slap a
label on the thing
and everyone seems confused they said he
was a racist
he must be a racist they said she was a
transphobic must be a transphobe
like you know it's literally costs
nothing to say that about someone
right there's there's just there's
there's no fact checking
that is even expected behind name
calling
it's a simple epithet right and in fact
some of these things
are it just simply takes the
form of uh a
description of a moral failing right
turf right turf is leveled as
as if it is a dire failure of
character and in fact it doesn't even
superficially add up to a description
of what it's it's talking about right
trans-exclusionary radical feminist a
traditional
minded person is not a radical you know
so
the basic point is it is like saying i
you know it's jacuzz
with a kind of empty placeholder and for
some reason people continually fall for
it
yeah yeah uh so
let's talk about an aunt named they of
course of course
okay so you may show my screen zack
this um was covered in a lot of places
uh this is a popular
version of a story uh called for those
just listening entomologists discover
new species of trap jaw ant in ecuador
that seems um you know classic taxonomy
somewhat
dull perhaps not that relevant um
but what it turns out it is called
is stromogenis ayers they
ears they sounds like pig latin yeah it
does
and so if we go actually um i'm just
gonna go to the actual
um the actual paper that was published
in zuki's
and we scroll down
it's you know classic taxonomy just you
know morphological data
indexes this all of these measurements
really not that interesting
until you get to this description
mesosoma
um interestingly here we have a
description of
uh this is all of the workers and then
when we get to description of the queen
and male
unknown so that's pretty typical but uh
this is this is a description of a new
species of a species new to
western science where you find the
workers but it's much harder to find the
queen
which is there's one in a colony in most
cases
or the males where very often there just
aren't any at the moment and that you
know that gets into
interesting aunt b and wasp uh
eusociality
and uh genetics which we won't go into
now but right after the queen and male
unknown section we have etymology which
i will
which i will read to us if i can make it
just a little bit bigger so i can see it
many cultures have recognized a spectrum
of genders between them beyond the
binary of male and female
not a sentence i was expecting in this
paper okay to continue
however by following a rule exampled in
the international code of nomenclature
for how to name species after
individuals
one might conclude only binary gender
assignments possible when assigning new
species names derived from latin
dubois 2007 provides clarification to
this rule stating that there is no need
to amend or latinize personal names
and therefore no need to assign gender
in contrast to the traditional naming
practices that identify individuals as
one of two distinct genders we have
chosen a non-latinized portmanteau
honoring the artist jeremy ayers and
representing people that do not identify
with conventional binary gender
assignments
strumogenesis ayers they the they
recognizes non-binary gender identifiers
in order to reflect recent evolution in
english pronoun use they them and there
and address a more inclusive and
expansive understanding of non-neutral
gender identification it goes on
and talks about who this artist and
activist was and why
um and it turns as it turns out sort of
the the
ps resistance in this uh is that
uh we learn in the acknowledgments
that uh quote we thank musician and
artist michael stipe
for contributing to the etymology in
honor of a hero to many and a dear
friend to those that knew him so michael
stipe helped write that etymology
uh description which um boy i would have
thought
i would have hoped for more from him but
uh
are we sure that's not an oblique
reference to a song or something
which the the um
the credit given to michael stipe
clearly indicates that he
participated in thinking through how to
name this app
that is um yes and that is described in
the various
um the various other articles about this
that aren't the scientific article
i will point out that the article that
they
claim finds uh
finds no that basically sets the stage
for them to name this specific epithet
they uh in fact does no such thing
here we have again just super
tedious really uh taxonomic literature
the dubois 2007 article called genitives
of species and subspecies nominated
derived from personal name should not be
amended
uh this is this is taxonomy for you guys
like this this is this is
really getting into the nitty-gritty of
how it is that you name things
because they're you know there are rules
and there are expectations about how you
follow
you follow them and from the abstract
article 31 of the code allows to form a
species or subspecies
from a personal name using a nomin in
the genitive case
some zoologists have construed this rule
as meaning that such phenomena should
always end in i if dedicated to a man
or an ae if dedicated to a woman etc etc
a detailed analysis shows that the
latter is wrong and that the original
spelling
including its ending of any new nominee
based on a personal name should not
be modified so the article they
cite to excuse their adding they to the
end of a latin name of a new ant
actually says no you shouldn't do
exactly what you've just done
and just one more thing before we riff
on this a little bit
we have uh i pulled up
i pulled up but now have lost on
antwicky.org
one of your favorite sites and mine okay
of course yes
um i remembered that two of our friends
when we were faculty at evergreen who
left before we did
jack longino uh internationally renowned
ant
ant taxonomist and his wife nalini
nadkarni
internationally renowned canopy uh
expert and uh
and ecologist ecologist
yes uh he had found jack had found
a new species of ant that he had the
honor of naming and he in fact
named it uh proceptoceras i'm probably
butchering that pronunciation of the
genus but the specific epithet that is
the second name
in the latin binomial which is the
scientific name of the species is nalini
he named it for his wonderful wife
and he did not add the the latin
ending which had become fairly popular
to add
he knew back in i think this was early
this is 2002
uh that you needn't and that it would
have distracted
and certainly you know nalini is no they
but uh it would have been absurd to add
an
english pronoun to the end of a latin
specific epithet nalini is so hard
hard-working that she could be a they
in the sense of being many people but
she's she is a she's a badass
tree-climbing tropical ecologist
yes completely incredible yeah
completely incredible as is
as is jack um but zack uh may i have my
thank you
um so
especially in an aunt especially in an
aunt
right where actually the distinction
between female and male
is so clear that females literally have
twice the genome that males do there's
no there's no
there's no they in ants well not only
that
they didn't find any males which is not
surprising they probably weren't present
at the season that this ant was
discovered but
would it have been all right for them to
declare some of the ants that they found
male on the basis that that would have
been uh
more i don't know uh
equal i find the sex ratio unfair right
what do you mean there's a hundred
percent females they found
okay so the work so for those of you who
who aren't intimate with ant ecology
uh when they say workers it's all
females it's all females so
the point is they're making grand claims
about
biology being non-binary that
they're making absurd claims about the
fact that
recent evolution of language well okay
there
yeah maybe again with the sociology of
epistemology
frankly right and so you know okay if
this is evolution let's be technical
here
right you've got two things going on
you've got uh
noise and maladaptation on one side and
then you've got adaptive changes which
will
stick and be augmented over time and
they have
leapt to the conclusion that the absurd
embrace of new
pronouns which are not necessary right
you can be
uh perfectly honoring of trans people
with the existing set of pronouns right
this well and i mean i don't think this
is even about trans this is this
this is this further nutty you know for
even nuttier than trans ideology i'm not
saying trans is none but trans ideology
is nutty
and this non-binary thing where well
i don't fit 1950s era gender norms
therefore i'm a they
what the hell i hope none of us exactly
fit 1950s gender norms at this point and
that doesn't make any of us a thing
right it doesn't make any of us a day
and there's useful information
in the pluralness or singularness that
is lost so you're actually degrading the
capacity of language to convey things
and to uh
yes yeah so anyway there's something so
troubling about this some
you know people who on the one hand
understand biology well enough to
realize that they only have female ants
and that that's not that surprising
right for this video it's sufficient to
make a whole new species because it's
it's fairly common because the males are
implied right
we know that they're there we just
didn't see them
right males are implied the males are
implied
right um but you know yeah the absurdity
of this
and you know i just think the arrogance
of
people using the scientific voice and
indeed the scientific literature and the
scientific
form in order to make an absurd
and obviously political signal of their
own virtue for which i'm certain that
they were heralded by people
right this is not the place right this
is
not the place not the place right if you
want to have that discussion about
whether or not we should
change the language all right we can
have that discussion but
you're borrowing the scientific
literature to you know to pull a fast
one
and you're doing so in the context of
creatures that
frankly you know so predate any of this
human absurdity
that the idea of sort of imposing it on
them as if it's their obligation to
broadcast your virtue is just
absurd yes it is yes it is
um to finish up i wanted to share a poem
that i saw in northwest portland this
week and then you wanted to have us do
two quick
uh what we're calling pro bono ads pro
bono ads and these
these are these uh enhance your life
that's the
the key key that's right
so zachary you may show my screen
i um in one of these situations that's
that might sometimes be a free library
and exchange library on a
street corner i found this poem this
week and i'm going to
uh no no i've i've got a different
picture here
when this is over it's called by someone
named laura kelly fannucci
when this is over may we never again
take for granted
a handshake with a stranger full shelves
at the store
conversations with neighbors a crowded
theater
friday night out the taste of communion
a routine checkup the school rush each
morning
coffee with a friend the stadium roaring
each deep breath a boring tuesday
life itself when this ends may we find
that we have become more like the people
we wanted to be
we were called to be we hoped to be and
may we stay that
way better for each other because of the
worst
that's a really good poem yeah yeah i
was struck by it when i ran into it
delightful that you found it outside
indeed yeah i was out getting a little
brisk walking outside and i found that
poem yeah that's great that's great yeah
yeah i have the sense the person who
wrote that is a wise person indian um
be cool to figure out who they are yeah
well if anyone uh here in portland knows
and knows her tell her we talked about
her and
and consider getting in touch it's a
great beautiful poem
um i think it's a natural segue to epoxy
putty oh
man is it yes so so this is this is now
pro bono ads we're not being paid for
these but we wanted to just talk about a
couple little things
yeah not being paid don't know if the
people who make this stuff are
decent people or not but we do know
something about the products that they
make
and we think you should too so in our
family we have uh
i guess it's an aphorism okay and the
aphorism goes like this
epoxy it's the adhesive for when you're
done [ __ ] around
um so i i believe in this i know your
proxy is really uh you had me take epoxy
and epoxy putty i believe when i was
out in the field madagascar you mean
you'd be crazy to go into the field
without it i would have been
you really would and the secret you
should all know are the epoxide bonds
which happen to be triangular which
makes them very strong they're really
called epoxide
oxide bonds you didn't just make that up
i kind of think you did oh
i'm pretty sure i didn't if if it's not
true i was lied to but no
triangular bonds are the key to making
the stuff so darn stable
and it is available in so many different
kinds that are useful for all kinds of
crazy things i am a huge fan of five
minute epoxy
because very often you can't figure out
how to clamp something but you can hold
it still for five minutes while
it hardens and so you can accomplish
things with five-minute epoxy
that are can't be done any other way
but what i want to talk about today is
epoxy putty and this is the you know
this is a sort of professional version
you find this
in the plumbing section it's not in the
adhesive section in general it's in the
plumbing section of a really
good hardware store and it's a very
interesting substance as heather
mentioned it is something i take a lot
of into the field because it solves
problems you can't solve any other way
so i was trying to figure out how to
demonstrate what this stuff can do
and it appears that you have destroyed
one of our bowls well i wouldn't say
destroyed i would say i have enhanced
one of our bowls
um hmm there's supposed to be a uh
clamp here that i don't seem to see
where is the clamp gone
well i'm not gonna be able to
demonstrate it with the clamp which is
true
did the cat eat it unfortunate how did
you see it
i i don't see a clamp here comes our
producer here comes zach looking for a
clamp
all right i'm going to describe here
suppose that you had this
bowl and for some purpose you needed to
affix it
to one of these arms right so that you
could do something
cool like suppose you decided to take
your podcast
and embrace a busker model for funding
it
and you needed a uh a bowl
you need an extension arm on your bowl
you need your bowl to be able to attach
to your microphone stand for example but
how the hell are you going to do that
you can put a hole in the bowl but then
you breach its integrity um so you know
you could try to weld something to it
that had
threads that would allow you to connect
to a tripod fitting like that but who
has the time to weld these doors
and you know let's suppose that the
fitting that you wanted to attach
happened to be aluminum and your bowl
happened to be stainless steel
it's gonna work right you might be able
to solder that but you can't weld it in
any case
epoxy putty this stuff is a
putty that comes in two parts which are
in a
basically it's got a outer and an inner
core they're two different colors so the
distinction epoxy comes liquid
in two tubes and you mix them and this
is this is a solid it's a putty
two cores you mix them together yeah you
mix them together and it will get
into the the grooves in your hand but it
wears off pretty good
anyway it's this putty stuff and it's
you maybe you can see it's got it
inside of one color and an outside of
another color and you mix them until the
colors become
uniform that's when you know you're
ready to go and then you can
you can make a very powerful attachment
point like this
let's say you were lacking that fitting
you could also put a little grease
onto your threads here and you could
wrap the epoxy putty around it you could
make corresponding threads you could do
anything you want
but the point is that allows you to take
two things that nobody envisioned
you were going to connect like this arm
here and this bowl
and make a very fine connection very
strong stuff because of those epoxide
bonds you know
and uh triangular epoxide bonds yeah i
was paying attention you were paying
attention which is awesome
um right but uh for example you know
there you go voila you you're now in a
position to do buskering with your
i think it's busking is it busking i
don't think it's buskering i don't know
okay well busking you could do busking
you know and people could throw coins in
your microphone stand attached
bowl but anyway here's the thing this is
not a very good demonstration of what
you could do with it but you can
extrapolate from what i've done here
which isn't all that useful
the things that you might do which would
be super useful and the basic point is
look
you know you will seem to the outside
world at least 20
smarter for having this stuff right one
recommendation
yes ask your partner or whoever else you
live with
before you start applying it to their
bowls
we'll talk about that later but look you
know as you know this bowl was not
precious to me
the bowl the bowl was not fresh i'm i'm
fine with it i believe i can recover
that bull
enhanced as it may be i believe i could
downgrade it back to
to where we were not easily of course
because of foxy putty's very very
hard sticky stuff that's tenacious it is
tenacious but you know
anyway this stuff it does wonders uh i
swear if the professor had had this
stuff gilligan and his friends would not
have been stuck
on that island they would have i don't
know we all would have been the better
they would have flown off in a coconut
airplane bound together with epoxy putty
or something like that
and i guess the last thing i will say is
remember rome wasn't built in the day
but it's only because they didn't have a
foxy putty
maybe we should stop there really yeah
okay i think i think that's good i think
you know we had we you know maybe we're
ready for another pro bono but i think
we should save it
save it yeah all right yeah okay well i
think that's great you guys
you can start extrapolating then now
extrapolating
with epoxy putty yeah about how they're
going to enhance their own lives with
this stuff
yes you see yes do do extrapolate but do
so carefully
yes always safety third as you like to
say i feel like i do like to say that um
and i know students who might have said
that have uh
have suffered great harm so so far it's
worked yeah
true um all right do we have a thumbnail
for this week or not yet
boys no worries we don't need one yeah i
mean we're gonna need one
but i don't know what it is yeah um oh
someone knows we're ending okay yes
uh for those of you just listening our
deputy producer who's sitting on the
table the whole time has just stood up
and revealed his ears to the audience
all right we will be back next week for
episode 82.
if you are watching we will be taking a
15-minute break and coming back with our
live q a during which we will answer
your super chat questions
we also every week answer one question
that's been voted on from the discord
server every week you can get access to
the discord server at either of our
patreons
other things you can access at our
patreons are right
right now you can go onto mine and um
at 11 up level and pose a question to be
considered
in the q a the two hour q a that we do
on the last sunday of the month
and at brett's there are higher dollar
amount conversations on the first
saturday and sunday of the month
in the morning we encourage you to
subscribe and like and share
this this channel and videos on this
channel and also from the clips channel
dark horse clips
which is really taking off and we are we
are thrilled about that you can always
send logistical questions
not super chat questions not content
questions but logistical questions
to darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
our moderator will also share for
instance a p.o box that we have we have
we have been receiving some really
remarkable
things from people um and uh and we
appreciate those
those things and maybe
maybe that is it as always i will advise
that you
be good to the ones you love and that
you eat good food and that you get
outside
get outside get outside all right
see you soon
[Music]
you